i'm going to ask you guys here if you
could hear a rap about anything in the
world what would it be about so
everyone think of a word a topic or a
phrase you'd like to hear a rap about
there are three rules number one no food
number two no animals they're the most
common suggestions our brains think of
don't say
dog or cheese you know the number three
don't be too obvious don't say brexit or
trump
don't say the queen don't say the
revolutionary war because i still feel
quite bitter about that
the best suggestion anyone ever said was
9th century crop rotation
just so you know you that's the
intellectual high ground you can aim for
that if you want uh we'll take five
suggestions i'll divide the room up so
everyone gets a fair go
uh i will come to this segment first
what do you want to hear a rap about
guys
teacher are you a teacher what do you
teach
oh thank you very much for you said
marine bio
and then i looked to you being like i
didn't yeah
as if i didn't know what bio was no
that's okay i just didn't know
aren't you like a professor then yeah so
don't do yourself down
you're a professor that's cool yeah
that's cool good
cool what a tense interaction this is
for some reason
i just never met a marine biologist who
refers yourself as a teacher rather than
as a professor cool
that's cool so a professor of marine
biology great suggestion
guys let's try and be less threateningly
aggressive towards me from now on
um this side of the middle what do you
want to hear a rap about
shakespeare shakespeare um is there a
particular aspect of shakespeare a
particular play that intrigues you
othello thank you very much for helping
the person out over there like
that prick doesn't know any plays
okay cool um othello so
is that one of your favorite shakespeare
plays yeah cool what's your favorite
who's your favorite character in othello
okay well really any idiot could say
that couldn't they
who's your favorite character in the
lion king the lion king
actually
cool so a professor of marine biology
othello um let's come to you guys over
here
what do you want to rap about
borderline personality disorder
um when i was a young man living in
london i used to work for mental health
charity and i
knew nothing about borderline
personality disorder then i interviewed
a woman with it i was like
ah it's probably really fun she probably
does all these different things i was
like
so talk about how it's affected you she
was like want to put my baby in and
true facts um cool bpd
and uh that's what's what it's called
the acronym that's what the people in
the know
call it guys guys over here what you
want to rap about bearing in mind that
so far we've had three of the driest
suggestions i have ever
been served up wait well okay so there
were two
you said gigolos and hoes and you said
red light district in amsterdam almost
as if you have a telepathic link
liverpool is kind of included in the
hoes aspect of that
i you don't know this but liverpool is a
great city go and visit it um it
genuinely is i'm a big fan of the pool
so i i feel that gigolos and hoes and
red light street and amsterdam kind of
all bundle into one so the red light
district now stand with the gigolos and
hoes marine biology professors othello
uh bpd let's get one final one and i'm
gonna say
let's make this um real good and we can
come to the back of the room because i
feel you guys got left out right back of
the room what you want to hear a rapper
population growth and i love how you
ended that on like a rising inflection
kind of you know mirroring what is
happening with population at the moment
it's uh
about every 10 seconds like 40 births
and about 11 deaths it's unsustainable
guys just so you know i'm afraid
population growth beat you to the punch
there
although we do need another agricultural
revolution to support the population
growth on this uh overburdened planet
so what this is what you want on a
friday isn't it just five
thi i mean one of them admittedly quite
fun you know red light district
but the rest of them really just a
somber mood
okay well we're going to have some fun
with them what i'm going to do i'm going
to take all those suggestions and put
them into
an incredible freestyle wrap made up on
the spot none of it's prepared none of
it's written
none of it is rehearsed um it'll be
about the red light district in
amsterdam population growth
othello borderline personality disorder
and marine biologist professors and
don't worry it won't be anywhere near as
atrocitially bad as you're expecting a
privately educated middle class white
boy to be
thank you very much those of you who are
on board with this if we can drop the
beat good sir let's have some fun
everyone's sitting there silently going
what the heck is gonna happen
[Music]
yeah dispersed knowledge standing at the
classroom sitting in the college got a
blackboard making sure my students all
know
if to the seaside they might go look
over there i offer an apology
sea level rising more biology to study
that's a good thing
even if we drown i like to get my boat
my team we go
down look at the marine life it's so
nice study marine biology
my advice is to make sure you stay away
from the shore
get down deep right to the sea floor
work out scuba diving bee
hench maybe dig down deep right into a
trench
the sea life there you can observe it so
many species much
more verdant than anywhere else you
might discover
anglerfish maybe sea cucumbers giving
threads when they feel scared
if i want to see ladies with dead
breasts and buttocks
their adventure to amsterdam i'm going
there in december
to do a show not to get wild i've got
the face
of a very young child i will go right up
to the windows and say check out
the jiggles and the hoes oh i look at
the hips this way
side to side the red light district is
so alluring to me
i take my wallet i say which girls
really really want it they all turn
their backs and they go inside i'm like
wow that reaction was
extra snide they didn't want nothing to
do with me
i flip on a dime like i got bpd i'm not
making life of an actual
illness it's really horrible when i
discussed
this with a lady who cooked a baby i was
like oh no
that [ __ ] crazy but that's not the
sensitive way
so i was more somber with the words i
say i say wow
what a really difficult time you didn't
know which part of your life was thine
thine a word used by shakespeare sixteen
hundreds yeah
come here we got a nice show called
arthelo
is he black or is he white you won't
know until you go
there standing on the floor there was no
seat wow
look at this more from morocco and er go
he's the antagonist
we all know desdemona she was the lady
about her affection went crazy othello
was like i like her iago said two
but then he had a plan that he started
to brew he wanted to betray him because
he felt offended he was like this guy
that i have befriended
if you don't know the plot there's no
hope i'll try and explain population
growth
now in the world like 7.6 the clock
moves on billions just kicks
where the people are you gonna find
there probably in india
probably in china population growth
going through the roof
if you're in japan i'll tell you the
truth it's actually declining about 1.5
hard to see how the population can
survive no thriving
people get into a couple and then they
say yeah we'll have less than a couple
of kids
just one but how do you do 0.5 it
doesn't make sense
i'm gonna hand jive and wave around and
say we must
we'll fix the population growth elon
musk could save it he would help us
come from afar move the population right
up to mars
he'd be like yeah earth we should
abandon it and start new population on
the red planet there you go
you